winter is coming and now i remember why
that's a good thing Game of Thrones
Season three Episode three walk of
punishment all right in my reviews of
the last two episodes I pretty much
complain about how not a lot has
actually been going on I complained
about some other stuff too but honestly
most of that other stuff probably
wouldn't bother me except it stood out
all the more because so little is
happening that's not the case this time
now we're moving forward the thing is
there isn't actually all that much more
plot actually happening in this episode
but it's just presented so much better
and it feels like there's more going on
we've got a destination now seriously
just one character saying you know to
look out there you never know there was
a war going on just to have somebody
knowledge that it went a long way to
taking the curse off it some other
highlights Daenerys is in full on strong
growing leader mode which means I like
her this time Tyrion becomes the Royal
accountant now I'm gonna be really
interested to see to how he takes this
pretty menial looking position and turns
it to his advantage cuz you know he's
going to that's what he does Robb Stark
feels more like a king and a leader than
ever before and that's just because of
one scene where all he does is chew out
his cousin finally the woman in red is
actually intriguing to me in this one
she's kind of annoyed me up to this
point that become partly because of her
being the embodiment of magic becoming
more prominent in the show which I
talked about before but also because
she's just the sort of that generic
background cultish figure it's I just
feel like I've seen that sort of
mysterious person pulling the strings so
often that i'm bored with her except
this time just little little nuances in
the performance she feels more human
than she has up to this point the White
Walkers feel really ominous and you feel
their presence that they don't even show
up in this episode and Jaime Lannister
gets some great material the more this
guy gets backed into the corner the more
I enjoy watching him it just feels like
everything's back on track and we're
back in form now that said there's a
couple of little things that are still
bugging me the sexual aspects of the
show they bother me a little bit in this
episode I haven't talked about it before
up to this point cuz it's just
they're it's part of the show at this
point now the sex position as it started
out in the first season I thought was
actually really clever that's a that's a
pretty nifty way to jazz up an
exposition seem cool the second season
it felt like they selected when they
were going to get more sexually explicit
pretty carefully or at least that's my
memory of it so that worked pretty well
this time it feels more like they're
doing it because it's just an
established trope of the show and it's
just kind of just kind of thrown in
there it's not bad but it's not feeling
as organic it's feeling a little more
force at this point it's I'm not just
talking about the nudity the subject of
rape gets brought up quite a bit in this
episode and it's to a degree that I'm
actually sort of skeeving a little bit
me that's a good thing I should be
skeeved by rape but it's it's making me
uncomfortable just as a viewer Mike
should I even be watching this and of
the number of times rape gets introduced
across a number of different stories
there was really only one time where I
was like okay I get why that's there I'm
not enjoying it but I understand why
it's there the rest of the times it was
it was kind of gratuitous even though
all this rape talk did set up that
brilliant line there's a beast in every
man that stirs when you put a sword in
his hand that's a fantastic line I'm
just not sure it was worth it the other
thing and then this is kind of big the
case of the show all long as we get up
we get quite a few new characters
introduced and they just sort of show up
they just kind of appear in the show
expects you to get who they are and
where they fit to all this and just move
forward with the whole thing and I I
respect the show for having high enough
expectations of our of its audience that
we're just gonna be able to grab it and
go but sometimes I wouldn't mind a
little hand-holding on this really I
should be used to it by now but I had to
keep backing on my going away yo who are
you again and you're related to who how
and have we seen you before I can't
remember like that I would have to look
up somebody would show up and be like am
I supposed to recognize you from earlier
because I don't or are you just knew
minor quibbles aside this is the show as
I remember it now as I remember loving
it so it's great just to see it back in
form thankfully as I hope those first
two episodes we laid the foundation now
they're actually building something on
it oh this episode serves as a nice
reminder that nobody does holy crap
closing moments to an episode like Game
of Thrones does
oh you know what I'm talking about and
until next time this council is
adjourned